foreign
Caitlyn where are you from originally
um I'm from the valley the Canoga Park
area
tell me about your family you had both
your parents grown up
I'm adopted so um I was adopted at Birth
my parents are a lot older than most
average parents
um but yeah
how would you describe your childhood in
general my childhood was really good
um I mean I was an only child but I
still really enjoyed it except once it
got to be around like
12 and 13 is when things started to get
a little bit like
not so good like I started getting
bullied in school and things like that
so
what were your high school years like
um it was really rough when I was first
in high school in my freshman year I got
groomed online
and I ended up being raped by a much
older man
when you're how old when I was 14.
how'd this come about
so um this man approached me online like
on Facebook
and I you know he was very interested in
me like I you know I didn't really knew
what he wanted but
um over time he groomed Me Slowly to
come over to his house and I would come
to the house I this happened like twice
I came to the house and you know he made
me do like oral sex on him and stuff and
then the second time I went to his house
which I don't understand why I did that
to this day but
um
you know he I told you know he took me
to the bedroom I didn't hear anybody in
the house like I had once heard before
and
um I told he started taking my clothes
off and you know I said I'm not ready
for sex and he was like oh that's okay
and he put He put me on the bed and he
um he raped me anally from that point
um it went I I may have blacked out or
something I don't remember but um when I
when I came to uh it had gone from day
to night so I don't know how long it
happened but um it was very brutal and
um yeah did you report him or tell your
parents or anything
um I was going I thought I was going to
take it to the Grave with me
um but when I turned 18 I had a complete
mental breakdown
and you know it came out of me and at
that point my whole family knew and I
decided to make a police report because
I knew that if he was still out there uh
he would be doing it again and I knew
before that um he had he had a prior as
well so he had raped another 14 year old
girl around the same time I told you
that I'm sorry he told he told you that
no
um I found this online on Megan's Law he
has a prior and
there's another victim
and where did this lead went to court
I'm sure
um yes uh it took a couple of years to
get to court but um my case was picked
up by the D.A and
um
and I went to trial I testified against
him
and
I you know I I struggled with it a lot I
had another like mental breakdown during
the time of the trial
and um but I got through it I testified
for a day and a half kinda and um yeah
so he was found guilty on seven counts
of sexual crimes
and he was convicted
sadly
um he absconded which is you know he's
on the Run uh that was when I was 21 and
I'm 26 now so he's been missing for
about five years so he's still out there
yeah
wow
are you still in contact with the
the law trying to track him down
um so my my case has been passed down
from D.A to D.A kind of over the over
this course of time
um to my knowledge there are D.A
investigators that do check from time to
time and I know he's on some uh
some lists like you know if he ever to
go on a plane you know he he would be
flagged immediately both on the regular
side and on the federal side
um but to there's no there's no like no
investigator there's nobody actively
looking for him there's just
investigators that seem to check from
time to time to see if they can find
where he is
and being silent for this for the years
that you were after it happened and now
coming out I'm sure both of these have
had an effect on you as an adult
oh yeah like when I first started coming
to terms with what happened to me when I
was 18 and I had that first mental
breakdown
um
I I started healing from there
um you know I went to therapy I've been
in therapy since 2015.
um
I've done different things like EMDR
recently which has helped tremendously
with the PTSD like thoughts and the
repetitiveness of them I don't have as
much tell me about EMDR
EMDR therapy is like
um eye movement reprocessing and
desensitization I think and um basically
you
you kind of
relive this event
you know so that enough so that you you
start to almost become desensitized to
it in a way that's probably not the best
way to describe it but there's there's
I've moved it's alongside eye movement
which they found has helped right yeah
um it's currently one of the number one
uh therapies they use for PTSD and
um it helped me tremendously that's what
I've recently done and um getting a dog
uh I'm weird I like to name my dogs and
my animals after
um the people involved in my case that
helped me get through it
um so my my dog that I have now is named
Casey and she's named after
um the police officer that took my
report
interesting
EMDR helps you yeah it helped
tremendously
um
like I used to have a lot of anxiety
attacks at night and I used to have a
lot of nightmares and
um the EMDR helped kind of both of that
that's great that's great
and have you done any therapy or
anything like that yeah I've done talk
therapy
um and I'm with two therapists right now
um I've also like done the medication
side of it too I take a specific
medication for um for the nightmares and
that like completely changed the game
too I don't I pretty much rarely have
nightmares now
it's wonderful
are you afraid that you're going to run
into this guy at some point
like do you live in the same area
yeah when I was raped it originally
happened in my neighborhood uh it
specifically in Hidden Hills that's not
my neighborhood but
um he took me to his home in Hidden
Hills
and
um he lived very close so yeah sometimes
I am afraid of
of running into him
I kind of don't think it would happen
because
um in his prior he did flee to Mexico
before they found him and brought him
back and sentenced him but for that
previous prior but um
you know I I feel like he could either
be in Mexico or he could either be here
in Los Angeles still
looking back at everything that happened
to you what he wished you had done
differently
um obviously not talk to strangers
online but
um
in a way I I don't think I could have
changed what happened because
um this person was very good at what
they were doing and
convinced me very thoroughly to to do
the things he wanted me to do I mean
after I was raped I all I knew was that
I was hurt severely and I didn't want it
to happen again so I had stopped talking
to him from that point
um but he would always come back and try
to oh come back over to my house or oh
let's come hang out again over and over
and over again and I would even lie and
say like oh I'm I'm studying or
something like that and uh even though
my grades were horrible because of what
happened
and so I mean I don't think I could have
changed what happened but if I could
have I would have somehow tried to
prevent it
um
but I don't know that I really could
have yeah yeah in what ways has it
affected you emotionally
um
like
I mean other than having kind of PTSD
like reactions and having depression and
anxiety
um
you know it's been it's been a long time
trying to heal that and come to a point
where I can function every day so right
now I'm at that point where you know I'm
functioning every day and I'm still
trying to
you know become the adult that I want to
be and yeah
but your your life is moving forward and
you're able to do things yeah I'm I my
life is moving forward very well
um I you know I don't deal with what I
dealt with back when I was first
you know filing the police report and
stuff I was a mess I was completely
suicidal when that happened
and um I've come a long way from that
and um
now I'm just trying to take care of work
stuff and then see if I can even move
forward from that like follow any of my
dreams or things like that you know
do you have drugs ever become a part of
your life or anything like that
I didn't experiment too much in the very
beginning of when I when I was like
still 16 and get go going into adulthood
I mostly had experimented with weed but
then I did experiment with cocaine and
pills and stuff like that but it was
very short-lived because
um I did I did overdose on pills very
easily uh the I had like a two day
bender on pills and that was it I
overdosed and that was it
so I've I've abstained from doing any of
the hard stuff but I definitely smoke a
lot of weed
what are you afraid of now what do you
worry about
um
I'm afraid of falling apart again even
though I'm pretty confident that it
wouldn't happen I I am still afraid of
it
um because
going through all this in the past years
has been has taken a toll on myself and
my body and everything and um
so I guess I'm afraid of of having a
mental breakdown again but um
you know I try you know I pretty I
you know I'm confident that it wouldn't
happen again but for some reason it's
still fear but keeping it a secret as
you had been doing before you came out
that would have been probably more
destructive or no yeah it was it was
definitely more destructive I um I
definitely self-harmed a lot and I was
I was just a mess trying to keep it a
secret having anxiety having depression
and not even really knowing it
and um
you know I don't self-harm anymore I I
haven't in a very long time
but um life was very destructive when uh
before I had even ever told anyone were
there other ways other than the
self-harm that it was taking a toll
um I mean like I definitely like gained
weight and stuff like that but um
other than that it was a lot of it was
just the self-harm and the suicidality
that came with it and me trying to keep
it a secret on top of that how I was
feeling and the rape itself like
it just I was traumatized you know what
were your parents reactions when you
finally came out
oh
um
I mean
they
they really
um
I mean they wanted to help me of course
I think they were very sad that I had
kept it a secret
um you know my dad didn't really show
too much emotion
from when I had told but I
I knew he was really hurting inside you
know he didn't really let me see that
part of him that was really really angry
about it
and my mom I mean she was very emotional
I mean I remember one time I was getting
uh questioned by the investigators and I
told my mom like you know go in the
other room because I didn't want her to
hear
the details of it and she came in after
we were done talking to the after I was
done talking to the investigators and
she told me she was like I feel like
such a bad mom
and I told her and I was like no you're
not you know it you know
and you're not allowed to disclose his
information or name or anything like
that
um to my knowledge I'm I shouldn't be
disclosing
um his personal details or his name
um but I am trying to write a book that
will eventually reveal his identity
because I think people should be looking
for this guy I think he should be on
Most Wanted or something you know
especially especially because he's done
it before you
had your encounter with him and he's
probably looking to do it again yeah I
mean even when even when he had finally
raped me
um you know he was like okay let me let
me take you back to where you need to be
you know oh but I need to pick someone
else up first and I was like okay
and he picked up this other girl and
near my neighborhood
and she was like the same age as me
and that didn't stand out to me then but
it sure stands out to me now I mean he
was just you know like on and on so I'm
pretty sure he's still doing it you know
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned from this Caitlyn
um
one of the most important things I've
learned now is that you don't need to
forgive someone to heal especially if
they've committed such a heinous act on
you
um you know I I came across so many
people always telling me to forgive this
person for what they did to me and it's
like
you know the way I see it is like if
there's a God that's his job to forgive
you know it's not mine
and that has helped me the most you know
just
taking all those emotions and just
running with it in my life and refusing
to back down just because he took
something from me you know yeah your
case is particularly hard because he
he's he was doing it he's probably still
doing it and he got away with it
yeah essentially I mean I still feel
really good that I testified and he was
found guilty it's just that he absconded
before that sentencing period and they
lost him at that point but I still feel
really good that you know he was found
guilty and all that it's just the part
that of course he's he's nowhere to be
found but yeah
all right Caitlin thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I hope you
do well from here on out
and I hope they find this guy yeah
thanks all right thank you